E
PRESIDENT.
SEAN?
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, GREAT
ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU, CHAD PERGRAM.
AND THAT IS NANCY PELOSI'S M.O.
SHE DOESN'T LOSE VOTES ON THE
FLOOR.
SHE HAD THE VOTES, SHE WOULD'VE
CALLED FOR THE VOTE.
JOINING US WITH MAURICE
CONGRESSWOMAN ELISE STEFANIK AND
FORMER SENIOR COUNSEL TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP,
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
CONGRESSWOMAN, WE WILL START
WITH YOU.
WE SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS STARTED OUT AT
$3.5 TRILLION, ALTHOUGH IF YOU
USE JOE'S MATH, IT WOULDN'T COST
US ZERO, ZERO, PAY YOUR FAIR
SHARE.
WITH THAT MATH DOESN'T WORK.
NOW IT IS 1.75, MANCHIN STILL
SAYING HE IS STICKING AT 1.5.
DO YOU SEE, YOU ARE ON THE
FLOOR, DID DEMOCRATIC
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS GOING ALONG
WITH A MANCHIN-SINEMA-STYLE
BILL?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
DEMOCRATS ARE IN UTTER DISARRAY,
SEAN, AND THIS IS A LAME DUCK
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
NANCY PELOSI IS A LAME DUCK, AND
WE KNOW THAT BOTH JOE BIDEN AND
NANCY PELOSI AND THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS BEING
CONTROLLED BY THE FAR LEFT
SOCIALIST PROGRESSIVES THAT YOU
PLAYED EARLIER TODAY.
THE CORI BUSHES, THE AOCS, THE
CAMILLA JAYA PAULS, WHO DO NOT
REPRESENT EVERY DAY WORKING
AMERICANS AND WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PRICE TAG OF THE BILL,
SEAN, THEY ARE COOKING THE
BOOKS.
THIS IS GOING TO COST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OVER
$10 TRILLION IF YOU LOOK AT IT
IN A 10-YEAR WINDOW, THEY ARE
JUST EXPIRING THESE PROGRAMS
WHICH THEY HAVE EVERY INTENTION
TO TRY TO CONTINUE IN
PERPETUITY.
THEY ARE COOKING THE BOOKS TO
HIDE THE PRICE TAG FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND IT IS NOT
JUST THE FACT THAT IT IS THE
LARGEST TAX INCREASE AND THE
LARGEST SPENDING BILL IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY, IT IS RIDDLED
AND LOADED UP WITH FAR LEFT
POLICIES LIKE MASS AMNESTY FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, HEAT YOUR
HOME TAXES WE ARE HEADING INTO
WHAT WILL BE THE MOST EXPENSIVE
WINTER EVER IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY, SO THIS IS ABSOLUTELY A
BAD DEAL FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, BUT THE PROGRESSIVES --
THEY ARE CONTROLLING
NANCY PELOSI RIGHT NOW, WHO IS A
LAME DUCK SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> Sean: CAN YOU SEE A
SCENARIO, KELLYANNE, WE BOTH
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME, IS THERE A SCENARIO HERE,
BECAUSE THE MARGIN IS SO TIGHT
IN THE HOUSE, 4-VOTE DIFFERENCE,
THAT MAYBE THE SQUAD CAUCUS
PUSHES PELOSI OUT?
>> WELL, THEY MAY.
I THINK HER DAYS ARE NUMBERED,
AS THEY WERE, TO KEEP THE HOUSE,
WHICH THEY WON'T, THEY ARE
WALKING INTO THE KIND OF
SHELLACKING THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
CLAIMED HE HAD SUFFERED AFTER
THE 2010 MIDTERMS, AND FOR MUCH
THE SAME REASON: OVERREACH.
SENATORS MANCHIN AND SINEMA, WHO
ARE MORE ALIGNED WITH PUBLIC
SENTIMENT, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FOX NEWS POLL, 53% OF THOSE
POLLS SAID THEY ARE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT INFLATION.
NO OTHER ISSUE CRACKED 50% ON
THAT MEASURE.
AND YOU HAVE A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT AND A PELOSI WHO IS
NOT RESPONDING TO WHAT ECONOMIC
CONCERNS ARE VEXING AMERICANS.
IN FACT, IN OTHER POLLS, 58%
DISAPPROVE OF JOE BIDEN ON THE
ECONOMY AND 60% SAID BIDEN IS
NOT DOING ENOUGH ON INFLATION.
THE ANSWER TO INFLATION IS NOT
THIS OUT-OF-CONTROL SPENDING
THAT ELISE JUST DESCRIBED.
THE ANSWER TO INFLATION IS
MAKING SURE THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS
NOT DISRUPTED, MAKING SURE THE
COST OF EVERYDAY ITEMS ARE NOT
EXPLODING, AND THIS IS EVEN
BEFORE WE GET TO THANKSGIVING,
CHRISTMAS, THE JEWISH HOLIDAYS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE SPENDING MONEY,
AND THEY ARE GOING TO BLAME
JOE BIDEN FOR THE EXPENSE OF
THOSE.
LOOK, IF JOE BIDEN CAN'T
CONVINCE LIBERALS IN HIS OWN
PARTY TO SPEND OTHER PEOPLE'S
MONEY, HOW IN THE WORLD WILL HE
CONVINCE GLOBAL LEADERS ON THE
WORLD STAGE TO DO ANY OF THIS?
JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY, SEAN, IT
IS A MAN-MADE DISASTER.
THEY HAVE GONE DISARRAY TO TOTAL
DYSFUNCTION, AND I THINK
PROGRESSIVES ARE PLAYING
PELOSI'S GAME AGAINST HER AND
THEY ARE GOING TO PREVAIL.
THEY ARE 96 STRONG AND THAT
CAUCUS AND THEY ARE PLAYING THE
LONG GAME HERE.
THEY WANT US TO RECONFIGURE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF US THROUGH SPENDING
POLICIES.
AND THEY WILL PLAY THE LONG GAME
HERE.
I THINK SINEMA AND MANCHIN
SHOULD COME OVER TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, CALLED
RONNA McDANIEL'S TONIGHT,
CALLED DONALD TRUMP, CALL
WHOEVER YOU WANT, BECAUSE WE
WON'T CHASE YOU INTO BATHROOMS,
RUN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AGAINST
YOU AND YOUR OWN STATE ONLY
BECAUSE YOU AGREE WITH THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS THAT WE
DON'T NEED MORE TAXES AND WE
DON'T NEED MORE SPENDING.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW,
CONGRESSWOMAN, WE HAVE THE MOST
DEATHS FROM THE PANDEMIC IN
2021, THE WEAKEST GROWTH SINCE
THE PANDEMIC WITH JOE BIDEN, I
MEAN, LITERALLY, THE SLOWEST
GROWTH ON RECORD TO THIS POINT.
AND A VACCINE MANDATE LOOMING.
WE HAVE LESS THAN A MINUTE, WE
WILL GIVE YOU THE FINAL WORD.
>> WELL, WE HAVE SEEN THAT
INSTEAD OF DEALING WITH ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPACTING EVERY DAY
AMERICANS, WHETHER IT IS
INFLATION, THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS, DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
SHOVE THROUGH THIS MULTITRILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE, AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THE VEXING MANDATES,
SEAN, I AM FROM MY HOME STATE OF
NEW YORK, I REPRESENT NEW YORK'S
NORTH COUNTRY, WE ARE FACING
HISTORIC LABOR SHORTAGE AND THE
VACCINE MANDATE IS ONLY
EXACERBATING THIS.
THIS IS WHAT KELLYANNE IS
REFERRING TO WHEN THIS IS ABOUT
REMAKING GOVERNMENT, WHERE
GOVERNMENT IS CONTROLLING YOUR
LIVES.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT TO.
DEMOCRATS ARE WOEFULLY OUT OF
TOUCH, AND I DON'T THINK
NANCY PELOSI IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DELIVER THIS OVER THE FINISH
LINE.
JOE BIDEN IS RIGHT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE DETERMINANT OF
HIS PRESIDENCY, AND IT IS AN
UTTER FAILURE.
IT